know that faced with that risk the
british people
will want their government to continue
to fight to protect them youth and
that's what we're doing
night and day and yet the single
greatest weapon we bring to this fight
is the common sense of the people
themselves
the joint resolve of this country to
work together
to suppress kovid now
so today i set out a package of tougher
measures in england
early closing for pubs bars table
service only
closing businesses that are not coping
secure expanding
the use of face coverings new fines for
those that fail to
comply once again asking office workers
to work from home if they can while
enforcing the rule of six
indoors and outdoors a tougher package
of national measures combined with the
potential
for tougher local restrictions for areas
already
in lockdown i know that this approach
robust but proportionate already carries
the support of all the main parties
in parliament after discussion with
colleagues in the devolved
administrations
i believe this broad approach is shared
across the whole
uk and those who say
we don't need this stuff and we should
leave people
to take their own risks i say these
risks are not
our own the tragic reality
of having coveted is that your mild
cough
can be someone else's death knell and as
for the
suggestion that we should simply lock up
the elderly
and the vulnerable with all the
suffering that would entail i must tell
you
that this is just not realistic because
if you
let the virus rip through the rest of
the population
it would inevitably find its way through
to the elderly
as well and in much greater numbers
that's why we need to suppress the virus
now and as for that minority
who may continue to flood the rules we
will enforce
those rules with tougher penalties and
fines
of up to ten thousand pounds we will put
more police out on the streets and
use the army to backfill if necessary
and of course i'm deeply spiritually
reluctant
to make any of these impositions or
infringe
anyone's freedom but unless we take
action the risk is that we will have to
go
for tougher measures later when the
deaths have already mounted
and we have a huge caseload of infection
such as we had in the spring if we let
this virus
get out of control now it would mean
that our nhs
had no space once again to deal with
cancer patients and
millions of other non-covered medical
needs
and if we were forced into a new
national lockdown
renewed loneliness and confinement for
the elderly and vulnerable
and ultimately it would threaten once
again the education
of our children we must
do all we can to avoid going
down that road again but if people don't
follow the rules we've set out
then we must reserve the right to go
further
we must take action now because the
stitch in time saves nine
and this way we can keep people in work
we can keep our shops and our schools
open
and we can keep our country moving
forward while we work
together to suppress the virus
that is our strategy and if we can
follow this package together
then i know we can succeed because
in so many ways we're better prepared
than before we have the
ppe we have the bets we have the
nightingales we have new medicines
pioneered in this country that can help
save lives and though our doctors and
our medical advisors are rightly worried
about the data now and the risks over
winter
they are unanimous that things will be
far better
by the spring when we have not only the
hope
of a vaccine but one day soon and i must
stress that
we're not there yet of mass testing
so efficient that people will be able to
be tested in minutes
so they can do more of the things they
love that's the hope
that's the dream it's hard but it's
attainable and we're working
as hard as we can to get there
but until we do we must rely
on our willingness to look out for each
other
to protect each other never
in our history has our collective
destiny
and our collective health depended so
completely
on our individual behavior
if we follow these simple rules together
we will get through
this winter together there are
unquestionably
difficult months to come and the fight
against kovid is by no means over
and i have no doubt however that there
are great days
ahead but now is the time
for us all to summon the the discipline
and the resolve and the spirit of
togetherness that will carry us through
no
the last six months have been
unprecedented they've been the hardest
many of us have ever lived through
but through our collective efforts
across scotland we did beat covid back
as a result although too much heartbreak
has been endured
and too many families are grieving many
lives were also saved
but as we enter winter and with many
lockdown restrictions now
thankfully lifted the challenge is once
again
getting harder albeit from the very low
level we achieved in the summer
cases are now rising again in the past
three weeks they have
almost trebled and as the virus spreads
more people are being admitted to
hospital again and sadly dying
so we are once again at a tipping point
we must
act to get covered back under control
and protect the things that matter most
to us
in our global pandemic of a virus with
as yet no vaccine
we simply can't have 100 normality
no country can so we must choose our
priorities
our priorities are saving lives and
protecting health
keeping schools open restarting
nhs services ensuring care homes are
safe
and protecting jobs and livelihoods it
is to safeguard
these priorities that i must ask all of
you again
to make sacrifices sacrifices
for our national well-being they are not
easy but please believe me when i say
they are essential
we have decided that from friday there
will be a national curfew for pubs bars
and restaurants
they will have to close by 10 pm to
reduce the time people spend there
and from tomorrow we are all being asked
not to visit
each other's homes because we know that
this is often how the virus spreads most
easily from one household to another
there are exceptions for care of the
vulnerable extended households child
care
and trades people but generally by
staying
out of other people's houses for now we
give ourselves the best chance of
bringing kovad back
under control we can still meet outdoors
with one other household in groups of up
to six people
and because we know this is especially
difficult for children and young people
we've tried to build in more flexibility
for you
if you are younger than 12 there are no
limits on playing with your friends
outdoors
and if you are between 12 and 17 you can
meet your friends
outdoors in groups of six and you don't
all have to be from just two households
now for everyone adults and children
i know that today must feel like a step
backwards
but please know that thanks to all your
efforts over the last six months
we are in a much stronger position now
than in the spring
cases are rising but less rapidly than
back then
our test and protect system is working
well
it is tracing contacts and breaking
chains of transmission
we have much more information on how and
where the virus spreads
and we know what we need to do to
protect ourselves and protect others
and all of us have a part to play
so i'm asking everyone please follow the
new rules
they will make a difference if you can
and haven't already
please also go to protect.scott and
download the protect scotland app
so more people who might be at risk of
the virus can be traced quickly
and asked to self-isolate and remember
facts
face coverings avoid crowded areas clean
your hands and surfaces
keep two meter distance and self-isolate
and get tested if you have symptoms
finally i know that all of this has been
incredibly tough
and six months on it only gets tougher
but never forget that humanity has come
through even bigger challenges than this
one
and though it doesn't feel like it now
this virus will pass
it won't last forever and one day
hopefully soon
we will be looking back on it not living
through it
so though we are all struggling with
this and believe me
we are all struggling let's pull
together
let's keep going try to keep smiling
keep hoping and keep looking out for
each other
be strong be kind and let's continue to
act out of love
and solidarity i probably will never
find the words to thank all of you
enough
for the enormous sacrifices you have
made so far
and i am sorry to be asking for more
but a belief i hold on to and one i am
asking you to keep faith with
in the moments when it all feels too
hard is this
if we stick with it and above all if we
stick together
we will get through it thank you
you